[Music]
the man who passes the sentence
swing the sword
I've won every buzz
as I'm losing this war you lose what
everyone
is mine to torment the long night is
coming
and the dead come with it
hey youtubers happy Valentine's Day the
long night is coming so a visual Game of
Thrones Season six teaser trailer let's
break it down if you don't know where
this is this is the Hall of faces in the
house of black and white it was a big
arc from last season Arya is learning to
become a faceless person but the last
big lesson that she learns is that she's
not quite ready to wear the faces
there's this supernatural aspect to it
it gets super freaky it was a great way
to end the season so right now she's
blind but there are all these faces that
the faceless men cure and then used to
mete out their justice to mete out the
mercy of the many-faced God but all of
the faces that we see at the beginning
of this are Starks does that mean that
Starks are coming back and people will
be wearing their faces not necessarily
but actually I should have said careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far so the
things that these stark faces Ned Stark
Catelyn Stark Robb Stark are saying are
all things that they've said previously
on the show before they died they all
have something to do either with meeting
out justice literally like a Ned Stark's
case when Jon Snow chopped off Janos
Slynt head during season five Katalin
Stark yeah she really wants people to go
crazy but that's a little more
metaphorical show them what it means to
lose people they love could imply phrase
could imply Lannisters cousins they do
pan - Joffrey said I do think it's more
lannister centric just you know him
going off on that tirade they are mine
de torment I like the meta idea that
this is the showrunner speaking to the
audience as then we are there's to
torment but they're mixing a few ideas
here so it's a little misleading because
we see characters faces that we know are
still alive on the show or characters
that we know are coming back and then we
see characters that we might only see in
flashbacks I do think that we're gonna
see some stark faces in flashback like
Ned Stark Winterfell flashback this year
with bran and the three-eyed Raven looks
like they're in Winterfell having a
vision so I think if we're gonna see Ned
and Catelyn Stark I think that's how
it's gonna be
Robb Stark's a bit of a question mark I
don't think that Robb Stark and Joffrey
appear in any flashbacks but that could
be something that the show changes or
Joffrey could just be a memory that
Sansa has it does look like she's gonna
get down to some business this season
maybe not right away but after some
banners rallied to her cause it's just
that I'm expecting a lot of Sansa Jon
Snow Justice this season so it's almost
like these dead stark faces are speaking
to the Starks that are still alive as
well as everyone in general because of
jon snow's warning the long night is
coming if you haven't read the expand of
material that long night has only
mentioned in passing like in old Nan's
tales who's essentially this uber winter
that happened 8,000 years before Aegon's
conquest and immediately preceded the
building of the wall it led to the end
of the war between the forces of man in
their alliance with the children of the
forest and the forces of the great other
so like White Walkers Knights King I
spiders his Melisandre says it was kind
of like the war for the dawn as in the
dawn would never come if the forces of
the great other were not conquered and
they were so the wall was built in the
rest was history but now because of
what's going on in the north it seems
like that is coming back the long summer
is over winter is coming
think of hardhome and the night's king's
army is a walk in the park
imagine a never-ending winter with our
armies of whites and white walkers all
over the earth yes the long night would
extend to all hemispheres one of the
problems with history from that period
is that it's not recorded very well the
maesters hadn't arisen yet the maesters
are really good about recording history
so once the maesters became a big deal
that's when you start getting really
good details but what happened in the
past but it's rumored that the first men
were only able to beat back the forces
of the great other with the help of the
children of the forest so I think you
know because there's a lot of questions
the answer as to what the long nights
going to look like on the show but the
plans of the White Walkers in the
night's king are I think the three-eyed
Raven is going to convey that to Brant
and that's how we as the audience are
going to find out about it also through
Jon Snow's character as well because
Melisandre has a pretty good idea of
what's going on so I think whether or
not we see bran speak to Jon Snow in
visions because I do think he's still
underneath that tree and we're just
seeing a vision of this picture I think
that they'll both separately have an
idea for what's coming but I just love
how it pans out to this picture of the
faces of the main cast where it says the
long night is coming in the dead come
with it as in all these characters are
gonna wind up dead so just to repeat
they're mixing a lot of things you're
just because these faces appear doesn't
mean we're going to see them all again
but I do really like that idea in
roundabout ways like some of them are
still alive on the show that's how we'll
see them some of the faces will see in
flashbacks like Ned Stark I think and
then some like Joffrey we might only see
mentioned in passing like through
Sansa's storyline I would be really
surprised if we saw a Joffrey flashback
so let me know in the
what do you think of these faces do you
think that we'll see them all come back
on the show in one form or another not
like they'll come back to life but the
show will invoke them in very specific
ways and I should actually say a new
round of the giveaway so all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video because it's so
awesome that they're finally dropping
teasers I'm just gonna double the
giveaway it's to Amazon giftcard so
there'll be two giveaway winners I'll
post another video tomorrow based on
some of the stuff they talk about now
that we have an idea for what's going on
I have an idea for a couple of cool
bonus videos and congratulations to last
week's giveaway winner from that last
teaser video I posted Renier and Maltin
please be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I get your
contact details so I'm absolutely
freaking out about this teaser it's so
awesome it actually leaked online what a
happy turn of Valentine's Day events and
a quick reminder of Valentine's Day in
addition to Deadpool awesomeness
happening this weekend Walking Dead is
back so I'm gonna be posting a Walking
Dead video later tonight so why he is
wait for all those videos to post you
can click here for all my Deadpool
Easter eggs and you can click here for
all my Game of Thrones season 6 videos
they've actually been quite a few small
teasers so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you